YouTube Bethesda's pre-release review
policy we're unable to provide a full
pray review in time for its launch we
recently acquired the game and since
it's quite lengthy it might be some time
until we can deliver our final verdict
however having played it for close to 10
hours we are able to offer some early
impressions in the meantime and those
impressions at this stage are mixed if
you played the opening our demo of Prey
available on Xbox one and ps4 you know
that prey starts strong it leans on a
big narrative twist that pulls the rug
out from underneath you and it's very
effective in sparking curiosity we won't
spoil the nature of this revelation but
suffice it to say that it plants a seed
of doubt forcing you to question
everything and everyone around you thus
far that aspect of the narrative hasn't
developed into anything of note however
the lingering supposition of dishonesty
has been the main driving force behind
the story but otherwise it's been quite
uneventful that's not to say it won't
develop into something more interesting
and change of nuance are indeed showing
themselves slowly over time we'll be in
orbit next week I promise and it's early
hours pray want you to immerse yourself
in Tallis won the space station where
the game is set and soak in the story
the environments have to tell tell us
one is a wreck with upturned furniture
strewn around its rooms corrupted
companion robots marauding its hallways
and raging fires enveloping its
corridors the station has been overrun
by sentient alien life-form called - and
while it's clear they're the cause of
all this the exact circumstances of the
outbreak are still shrouded in some
mystery furthermore there's also the
question of who's to blame for it we're
not sure what its purpose is it's never
spread outside the containment cylinder
until now similarly praise gameplay
feels like it's yet to develop into
something unique mostly because the more
interesting abilities are deeper into
the various skill trees then I've been
able to reach up front pray is
surprisingly generous with the neuro
mode items that unlock skills but so far
I've only been able to develop a
rudimentary playstyle
I've spent the majority of my points
improving my health pool allowing myself
to repair broken turrets and expanding
my inventory space this in turn
translates to a vanilla combat
experience I'm using the glue cannon to
immobilize enemies and then bludgeoning
them with a wrench or emptying shotgun
shells into them in other situations
usually when I'm low on health for ammo
have opted to sneak around enemies to
avoid combat using laws who manipulate
their movements and methodically crouch
walking between furnishings developer
arcane austin has promised players that
they will be able to take on challenges
in a variety of ways and while that does
seem to be true so far the options i've
been given have felt uninteresting I've
made know of numerous block pathways I
will no doubt become available as my
skill set improves but as of yet my
pathway the game has been fairly
directed this honour to developed by our
Cannes France based sister studio
encourage players to achieve their
objectives through creative use of
powers my hope is that when more power
is available to me and pray alternative
opportunities will open up and combat
will allow me to be more experimental a
major sticking point for me so far is
the behavior of the mimic enemies as
their name suggests they have the
ability to shape-shift into any object
that is in the immediate surroundings
this means you can walk into an ordinary
empty room and not know that you're
actually seconds away from having a
mimic pounce on you the idea behind this
is sound it creates a constant sense of
tension but in practice as very quickly
become annoying
not just because mimics can attack you
when your back is turned and you're
focused on something else but also
because the appearance of a mimic is
signaled by a sharp shrill sound effect
that thanks to its overuse soon greats
it's designed to create a jump-scare
moment but since I was often looking in
another direction and away from the
mimic he always felt mistimed there are
other reservations I have with enemy
behavior in combat right now but I'm
hoping that given some time they'll
click into place at around 10 hours I've
been acquainted with the fundamentals of
the pray experience it all feels quite
familiar at the moment but I'm aware
that these are also building blocks I've
just unlocked the ability to use alien
powers which introduces an interesting
dynamic when you consider that Talos 1
is littered with sentry turrets that
attack life-forms with alien DNA I'm
also moving into a brand new area of
tellus one an accruing side quest as the
world opens up with any luck all of this
will start to coalesce into something
more worthwhile those are a few of my
early impressions of pray but as I said
it's a review in progress I'll be
spending a few more hours with it and in
time we'll deliver my full verdict make
sure to subscribe to GameSpot's that you
can see it when it arrives
[Music]